Und wie alt sind Sie, Herr Wagner?
Ich bin genau 60.
Wann wurden Sie genau geboren? Heute ist Ihre Gebissheit.
Am 1.7.65.
Ein... und...
Können Sie bitte noch mal sagen, es wird ein...
Am 1.7.65.
Und herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Wieso erst die Giften? Das ist Juli.
Sorry.
Juli.
Ja, sorry.
Und wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie so seit?
Ich habe noch 74 Kilo und ich bin 1.83 groß.
Okay, Herr Wagner, haben Sie sehr stark geschmätzt?
Seit wann haben Sie tatsächlich so geschmätzt?
Ja, das hat angefangen.
Ja, bestimmt schon vor einem Viertel.
Ja, so.
Aber jetzt wird es in der letzten Zeit, in den letzten 2, 3 Wochen,
ist es immer schlimmer geworden.
Und also hier oben im Bauch tut das sowieso so unterhalb der Brust,
so oberhalb vom Bauchnabel, würde ich sagen.
Ja, oh, und das sind solche Schmerzen.
Das zieht und ja, ist jetzt also in letzter Zeit richtig schlecht geworden.
Okay, wann treten diese Schmerzen auf,
nach dem Essen oder nach dem bestimmten Bewegungen?
Naja, ich würde sagen, sie sind eigentlich permanent da.
Okay, Herr Weber, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 59 Jahre.
59, wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 1.765.
75 oder 60?
65.
60.
Also 9965.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1.83.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Wie viel sind Sie?
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 32 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. März, 1900.
Was ist das?
82?
92, wahrscheinlich.
92, 92.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,82 Meter.
92.
Ja, das ist so.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Wie sind Sie in der aktuellen Gewicht?
Ja, ungefähr 85 Kilo.
95.
Wann sind Sie, Herr Dingerdissen?
Ich bin 64.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12. Januar, 1961.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,81 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktueller, wie sind Sie?
82 Kilo.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Baumann?
Ich bin 43 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 4. Juli, 181.
81.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 Meter groß.
1,78 Meter?
70.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Erzähl mal.
Etwa 85 Kilo.
85.
Okay.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten, Herr Baumann?
Ne, ich habe keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten.
Ja, super.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Doktor Raab.
Doktor Raab.
Raab, R-A-A-B.
R-A-B.
R-A-A-B.
Okay, alles klar.
Herr Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 69 noch.
69.
Okay.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 18.
19.
54.
Okay.
Herr Müller, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,74 Meter.
1,74.
Okay.
Kennen Sie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ja, das ist so immer um die 83 Kilo.
Mal ein bisschen weniger, mal ein bisschen mehr, aber 83 Kilo kann man sagen.
Okay.
Herr Müller, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Rentner zum Glück.
Rentner? Ah, okay.
Ja, genau.
Aber was haben Sie früher beruflich gemacht?
Ich war in der Stadtverwaltung angestellt.
Können Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ich war Angestellter in der Stadtverwaltung.
Okay.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ja, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind aber schon Erwachsenen.
Ah, okay.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei, aber wie gesagt, die sind Erwachsenen.
Okay.
Ich bin ein sehr junger.
Ja, das sind Erwachsenen.
Na, okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1.15.1970.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Das habe ich, ich bin ein bisschen kleiner geworden.
Ich war einmal 1.78.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Wie schwer ist es jetzt?
Wichtig, Frau Doktor.
Ich bin etwas schwer.
Ich glaube, bei 110 Kilo.
Alle Informationen sind wichtig,
über ihre allgemeine Gesundheit zu wissen.
Danke schön für die Informationen.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann wurden Sie geboren?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Geboren bin ich am 15. Mai 1971.
Und wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie jetzt so seid?
Ich bin 1,67 m groß und wiege 64 Kilo.
Ja, und 60 Kilo.
Verstehe, wie alt sind Sie, Herr Eidim?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 28. April 1900.
Was ist das, 83?
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich glaube, 1,83 m.
Und wie viel wegen Sie?
Ich mache so circa 75 Kilo.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Zimmermann?
Ich bin 67.
67? Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 2. Mai 1957.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin so 1,75 m.
Wie viel wegen Sie?
Ich wiege 78 Kilo.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Schmidt.
Mit DET am Ende?
Ja, genau.
Herr Zimmermann.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin 37 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin 1988 geworden.
1980?
1988.
Ach so, genau dort?
Ach so, 25. Januar.
Danke schön.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,80 m groß.
Und wiege momentan 75 Kilogramm.
75. Danke schön, Herr Schmidt.
Okay, Frau Hansen.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Bin geboren am 1.5. 1961.
1961.
Frau Hansen, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1968.
60. Und kennen Sie Ihr aktuellen Gewicht?
Mein aktuelles Gewicht ist so um 74 Kilogramm,
immer plus, minus, mal ein bisschen mehr, mal ein bisschen weniger.
Okay, 74 Kilogramm.